I'm just going to start with
congratulations it must be a very tough
day when everyone walks into a room
loving a movie and you have to talk
about it it's so fun and you know it you
know we've got enough of these where you
know you know
that's always like how are the kids
they're great the kids are great Ryder's
in college
no we're not going to talk about them
about the movie
loved it um I am so curious when Ryan
first approached you uh did he tell you
what the story was going to be and the
script and everything or did he say hey
I'm interested in you working with you
here's the script tell me what you think
well I had a different so for me I was
slipped the script which was very not
okay I love it
um
and I went after Ryan
so I was like I read it and was like
I need to meet Ryan and then when I met
Ryan and that for so for me I sort of
like gosh went after birdie and like
thank God this that you did and when I
was there's no one else in the world and
when I read it I was like I was like
this script is so it was so interesting
because I the first thing I thought was
my expectation of how is he going to get
out of New England you know what's that
going to look like and within five six
pages of the script you were so you were
already so invested in all of the
characters and in a new completely new
environment and totally new world of
people and I was just you know you're
you were right in there kind of like the
experience I would think of seeing it
for the first time
yeah I mean I I was a huge fan of the
first film um I love Ryan Johnson's
movies I mean my my son had just showed
Looper to us so we were like what so I
was already like in the uh you know Ryan
Johnson had just been kind of like in in
in our kind of like just in the world in
our house and then I was so uh we met on
Zoom
and then I read the script and then and
so it I kind of had to kind of pitch
myself basically pretty hard uh to Ryan
Johnson and
um I was just wanted in so badly also
because I just love
freaking actors so much and I having
seen the first one I just looked like it
would be so fun to be a part of an old
school Ensemble like that because EV it
just looks so bouncy and so so
deliciously
um
carved out the each character it just I
just wanted to be in a world like that
where every character was like
not to reference clue because I know
that's a big thing but like that it just
looked so specific that I just really
really wanted in in into that kind of a
World building kind of environment that
was funny and suspenseful and I I just
never done a genre like this before so
and with this kind of group of actors so
yeah it was it was I definitely pitched
myself pretty hard question which
apparently we're good at pitching yeah
so that we that's something we learned
about ourselves yeah and then we
ourselves well we pitched ourselves well
can I ask you when you were looking at
the schedule and you saw what you had to
shoot which was the day for each of you
that you had circled like I cannot wait
to do this oh great question I honestly
had a couple of those days uh for birdie
one of them what is the bedroom scene uh
the pool the that whole pool section to
me was just it was like let's go
um I would say those two but really all
of them I just couldn't get wait to get
into birdie I was like her body
everything like every day I just wanted
to like be birdie you know
um yes
you yeah I would say like the first I I
yeah there's a couple of scenes for me
it was it was definitely the um uh I
mean I don't even want to like I don't
know what happens you can't even say it
I can't even say it but there's a bunch
of big group scenes that I couldn't wait
to get into was it like the Midway like
a Midway group scene yes yes I know
exactly which one you're talking about
when people watch the movie they'll
understand yeah I have to go
congratulations pleasure to see you so
good to see you